warning this video contains spoilers for
The Last of Us season 1 episode 1 and
the entire Last of Us Part One game by
most accounts the premiere of HBO's The
Last of Us was a slam dunk in the eyes
of longtime fans of the game but what
crucial detail from the game got left
out the last of us Creator Neil druckman
told nerdreactor that the priority of
the game's story was to explore the
relationship between its two Central
characters Ellie and Joel druckman and
his team wanted to see if they could
successfully convince players that two
characters who are strangers to one
another at the start of the game could
grow to care for one another immensely
by the end thanks to the immersive
gameplay and the intense narrative the
writers inflict upon the pair they
succeeded by all accounts without the
interactive aspect of gameplay to rope
viewers in the last of us showrunners
were always going to need to make
significant changes to achieve the same
effect to druckman and series co-creator
Craig Mason's credit many of the changes
showcased in the premiere all but prove
that no one besides them could craft an
adaptation so lovingly faithful in its
deviation and EXP Mansion however
certain changes we witness in the pilot
could threaten the Integrity of the
project altogether despite the game's
heavy Reliance on relationships it seems
that the writers of the show decided to
heavily alter one of the central opening
plot points the relationship between
Ellie and Marlene while their friendship
may seem inconsequential to what Joel
and Ellie developed throughout the game
diminishing it Gravely undermines
elements of druckman's original story
especially its Infamous climax in the
video game the player is introduced to
Ellie in a shocking yet effective way as
Joel carries a critically injured
Marlene into her apartment Ellie lunges
from behind the door with a small knife
to protect her emitting her iconic first
line
away from me
this line of dialogue is key because it
clarifies that Ellie is acting out of
concern for her friend rather than
self-preservation in this scene Neil
druckman quickly establishes Ellie as
Brave selfless and caring while implying
that Marlene is a reliable caregiver to
players who have so far experienced
nothing but selfish survivalism this
Dynamic introduces Marlene and Ellie as
refreshing figures of Hope while the
video game accomplishes all this in a
matter of seconds the series spends
roughly six minutes without revealing
much about Ellie's genuine personality
any semblance of their friendship has
been erased and without it both
characters are indistinguishable from
everyone else it's revealed shortly into
the game that Marlene has been caring
for Ellie since her mother passed away
as such it can be inferred that she's
been more or less raised on the ideology
of the fireflies though she claims not
to be an official member it's clear that
Ellie believes in what they stand for
arguably the most damaging aspect of
Marlene and Ellie's altered history for
the TV series is that Ellie no longer
has a personal stake in the Firefly's
cause without this investment it's hard
to understand why she agrees to go with
Joel when she very clearly wants to be
left to her own devices while in the
video game she fights through enemies
for a future that she has clear
unwavering and optimistic faith in she
seems to trudge along in the series
solely out of a sense of obligation it
already seems as though the writers will
eventually try to pin Ellie's conviction
on an unseen history with Marlene or
something to do with her mother in
either case it's a shame if a series
with so much screen time has to rely on
off-screen events and interactions to
motivate one of its Central protagonists
what really sets The Last of Us Apart is
that it manages to be both emotionally
arresting and dramatically surprising
all at once Neil druckman's
establishment of Marlene as a reliable
caregiver not only helps players
empathize with her as a character it
also slightly conceals the game's final
twist Marlene is immediately introduced
as a hardened revolutionary who will
risk anything for her cause like any
good Storyteller druckman lays his cards
on the table from the start but he still
manages to surprise audiences at the
story's conclusion without sacrificing
anything he's built previously druckman
humanizes his characters so thoroughly
you almost forget Extinction looms just
over the horizon Marlene is quite
refreshingly presented as a hopeful
figure in a bleak future by making her a
reliable character with a deep emotional
attachment to Ellie and seemingly just
goals players aren't primed to expect
what she'll do to see those goals
through Neil druckman recently told the
New Yorker that he views the last of us
as an exploration of the limits of the
unconditional love a parent has for
their child for the climax of this
exploration to be satisfying Joel and
Marlene need to have one thing in common
by the time they see each other again in
Salt Lake City they both need to love
Ellie like a daughter in the game it's
clear Marlene's affection for Ellie a
strong and long-standing
but whatever it is you think you're
going through right now is nothing to
what I have been through
I knew her since she was born in the
series however Ellie is essentially
Marlene's prisoner the drama of the
game's finale is derived from the
similarity in how Marlene and Joel feel
about Ellie it creates this idea that
with the right argument one of them
could realistically persuade the other
in the series since Ellie has only known
Marlene for a day or two it's hard to
imagine the writers achieving the same
level of payoff Marlene is a soldier not
a parent of course her treatment of
Ellie would differ from Joel's in this
context the conflict shifts from a
contest of family to one of ideology
despite the missing setup of Marlene and
Ellie's history it's still possible that
the HBO series could pull off a
satisfying finale even with their
lacking relationship aside from Neil
druckman and Craig Mason's
well-established talents as storytellers
and Bella Ramsay and Merle dandridge's
exceptional performances as their
respective characters the show has
proven its ability to offer something
new what they've built so far may not
work especially well for the game's
climax but perhaps it will be perfectly
suited to some new twist they've taken
for the series after all no show could
ever be a one-to-one adaptation of the
game's original story arc there's also a
possibility that future episodes will
give Marlene and Ellie's relationship
more texture giving the Final Act the
mutual heartbreak it desperately needs
[Music]